＜まさき(以下ま)＞アァァァァン
＜はじめしゃちょー(以下は)＞はっはっは（笑）
＜ま＞絶対使うじゃん。ねぇ、それ絶対使うじゃ～ん。
（シャキーン）
＜は＞じゃあたまには、まさきから挨拶してみよう！
＜ま＞こんにちは！まさきしゃ...あ、「しゃちょー」じゃないwww
＜は＞おいおいおい（笑）
＜ま＞こんにちは！まさき取締役と！
＜は＞※△〇☆＄＃＆です。
＜は＞みんな！ポケモンは好きでしょうか？（まさきに対して）好きかい？
＜ま＞もちろん♡
＜は＞という訳で、ポケモンはですね、今や何匹になってるの？
＜は＞ただ今全部で774種類！いるらしいでございます！
むちゃくちゃ増えたねぇ～＜ま＞増えたねぇ～
＜は＞７７４だよ？
で、そこでなんですけども。僕は思ったわけですよ。
俺、ポケモンの声わかるんじゃねぇかなって。
＜は＞一応ポケモンのゲームはX、Y以外は全部ちゃんと全クリして割とやり込んでるんで、
X、Y以外のポケモンなら、全部声がわかるんですよ、ある程度。
トゥンルルルル（フシギバナの鳴真似）
トゥルントゥットゥ～、トゥルントゥットゥ～（ナッシーの鳴真似）
ってやつでしょ？
＜は＞トゥ～ルルルルル～、トゥ～ルルルル～
プ～ン
トゥ(↓)トゥ(↑)トゥン(↓)
キュゥゥン（高音）
ヌゥゥゥン（低音）
＜ま＞これ見せないと俺にしか面白さが伝わらない＜は＞あ、そっかそっか！そうだ（笑）
＜は＞トゥルルトゥルル～ン♪（ゴースの鳴真似）
コォコォコルルルン（コクーンの鳴真似）
＜は＞はい、というわけで今回はですね、
わたくしポケモンマスティングのはじめしゃちょーが
今からまさきにポケモンGOの中の初代のポケモンから適当にポケモンの鳴き声を流してくれるので
それがっ！なんのポケモンかを、確実に当てていこうかと思います！
＜は＞これすごいよね、わかる？＜ま＞すご～い。
＜ま＞わかんない。絶対俺は。
＜は＞俺はね、わかるよ。
＜は＞ただまじ、カブトとあのワンリキーのあの、「キュルルン」のチームがまだちょっと難しい。
＜は＞レベル１から順番にレベルを上げていきましょう。
で、間違えた瞬間、終わりでいいよ！よぉし！
＜は＞来いやぁぁぁ！！！
＜ま＞第一問は＜は＞はい。＜ま＞もう、超初級です。＜は＞OKです。
＜ま＞いいすか～？＜は＞はい。
＜ま＞一発で当ててくださいね。＜は＞OKです。
＜ま＞行きま～す！＜は＞はい！
「ピカチュウ！」（鳴き声）
＜は＞ピカチュウ～♡
＜は＞馬鹿にしてんのか、お前＜ま＞へへ（笑）
＜ま＞2問目も簡単にいきましょう！＜は＞はい。＜ま＞行きま～す！＜は＞はい。
「〇△※＆％＄ッ」（鳴き声）
＜は＞...。これはあれだねぇ。よくいるよね。＜ま＞うん。
＜は＞これはポッポです。
＜ま＞正解！＜は＞よっし！！まぁ、ここらへんは、ここらへんはいけます。
＜は＞３問目？＜ま＞行きます！＜は＞はい！
「〇△＃＄％」（機械音っぽい鳴き声）
＜は＞ルルルルル。ル～ルルルル。
バ～ルルルルル。バ～ルルルル。
＜は＞ゼニガメです！
＜ま＞正解！＜は＞よっしゃあああ！！！
＜ま＞すご～い！＜は＞これ結構すごくない？＜ま＞うん。
＜ま＞ちょっとレベル上げちゃおっかな～？＜は＞よぉし、来い！＜ま＞行きま～す！＜は＞はい！
「ピッピ～！」（鳴き声）
＜は＞これは簡単だよ、ピッピだよ、これは。
＜ま＞せいか～い！＜は＞こりゃピッピでしょ。そりゃ。
＜ま＞行きま～す！＜は＞はい！
「〇△※＃＄％」（機械音的な鳴き声）
＜は＞えっ！？
＜は、ま＞（笑）＜は＞もう一回、もう一回、もう一回！
「〇△※\＃＄％」（機械音的な鳴き声）
＜は＞ウワ～ウ。ウワ～ウ。
ブァブァ～ブァ。
バ～(↑)バ～(↓)
＜は＞ロコンだ。
＜ま＞せいか～い！！＜は＞よっし...！！
＜ま＞すご～い！＜は＞俺本当にわかるよこれ。
＜は＞え、俺、まじでポケモンマスターなの？（笑）
＜は＞よし、レベル６！＜ま＞行きま～す！＜は＞はい。
「ギィィィィン」（鳴き声）
＜は＞そんなヤンキーな鳴き声のポケモンいる？（笑）
＜は＞ちょっと、もう一回、もう一回、もう一回。＜ま＞行きま～す！
「ギィィィィン」（鳴き声）
＜は＞うわぁぁぁ....
＜は＞進化形とみたよ。＜ま＞あ～、いい線いってますね。＜は＞その声は進化形の声だよ。
ちょっともう一回。
「ギィィィィン」（鳴き声）
＜は＞草タイプっぽいなぁ...。ちょっと、もう一回、もう一回！
＜は＞ラフレシアじゃね？
＜ま＞せいか～い！！＜は＞まじで！？ほんとに！？＜ま＞すご～い！！
＜は＞俺、俺、え、え、すごくない？俺。
俺まじでいけそうだわこれ！
＜ま＞行きま～す！＜は＞はい！
「ゴオォォォォ」（鳴き声）
＜は＞ほっ
＜は＞ちょっと待って、もう一回、もう一回、もう一回。＜ま＞行きま～す！
「ゴオォォォォ」（鳴き声）
＜は＞ブ～ブ～ブブ
＜は＞え？そのタイプのポケモンはね、ロコンとキュウコンなんだよね。その流れは。
キュウコンはでも声高いんだよ。ロコンは「ブ～(↑)ブブ～(↓)」キュウコンが「ル～ルル～（高音）」
（鳴き声）
「ブ～ブ～ブブ」
むずいな～、これ難しいでしょ？
もう一回ください。
（鳴き声）
＜は＞進化してんな？進化してんのはわかるんだよ。
え～！！むずいむずい、本当にむずい。
＜は＞え、こんなポケモンいないよ～？＜ま＞いるよ～
＜は＞あっあっあっあっあっ。キタかも、キタかも、キタかも。＜ま＞おっ！？
＜は＞当てていい？ゴローンでしょ？
＜ま＞せいか～い！！＜は＞っしゃぁぁぁぁぁぁ！！！
待って、折れそう、骨が。
＜は＞いいぞ～。次８問目？
＜ま＞ここら辺で、俺的に好きなポケモンいきます。
＜は＞あ～！いいよ！なんでもきて！いける、今なら。
＜ま＞行きま～す！＜は＞はい！
（鳴き声）
＜は＞え...。
＜は＞え、ちょっと、もう一回、もう一回！
（鳴き声）
＜は＞顔ひきつってきた、難しすぎて。もう一回、もう一回。
＜は＞「ウウ～」の進化なんだよたぶん。え、まじわかんないよ～。え？
＜は＞サイドンでしょ？
＜ま＞違う。
＜は＞待って待って待って、わかった。カイドスだ。
＜ま＞違う。＜は＞わかった。ストライクだ。＜ま＞違う（笑）
＜は＞わかんない、もう無理無理無理！
＜は＞べトベタ～。べトベトン？？
＜ま＞正解！！
＜は＞無理だよ...。
（鳴き声）
＜は＞嘘だ、こんな声してないよ～。
（違う鳴き声）
＜は＞ほ...もう一回、もう一回。
＜ま＞行きま～す。＜は＞なんだそのリズミングな！
（鳴き声）
＜は＞あ～、カブトだ！＜ま＞正解！
（違う鳴き声）
＜は＞もう一回！
（鳴き声）
＜は＞ドガース？＜ま＞違う。＜は＞またドガース？違うな。絶対違う。
＜ま＞大ヒント！....カリブラのメンバーです。
＜は＞モンジャラじゃん（笑）
＜は＞ぜひそこの！ポケモンのみんな！...違う、ポケモンじゃない（笑）
＜は＞ポケモントレーナーのみんな！ぜひ皆さんも、ポケモンの声当てクイズやってみてください！
＜は、ま＞バイバー